we are joined today by one of the stars
of the new Fantastic film I feel very
lucky to have seen it Scream Six that's
right
[Applause]
here Dad Butters by the way I've been
checking out Butter's Instagram account
[Applause]
I know we're drooling over here where
did this piece come from this is
Nordstrom Rack I went this morning with
my mom because I was like oh wait I need
to wear something so by the way and I
met your mom the other night and I
bonded with her about how much us moms
just like want to see our kids Happy And
thriving and she had all the pride where
did this go down so I was literally
walking to go to Times Square with the
directors Matt and Tyler and then
um there's like some kind of filming
thing and someone's like oh yeah Drew
Barrymore's filming and I was like wait
what and she's like yeah she's to your
right and I was like what and then you
were just right there and I said hello
yeah and then I said I'm Casey Becker
yeah you said you Casey Baker and then
at first I was like Casey oh my God
scream and it was oh my gosh it was so
cool and random well I had just seen the
film and you're just so incredible in it
that means
I mean
as someone who you know really cares
about this franchise and and knows it
and just you know as a fan myself also
like I'm I can see it from every angle
yeah you're so incredible thank you so
much
can you tell me anything about the movie
oh um well it takes place in New York um
which is a big exciting they've never
done that yeah right yeah it's crazy
it's it's kind of like a new psychotic
playground for Ghostface you could say
you know there's so many new ways to
kill people
and yeah it's scary well you know you're
just on such a high right now too I mean
things are really going well like you
had like a one day where you got like an
Avengers and like a like another part in
the same day yeah no it's crazy you know
that um
tell us what were they well um I was I
think I was 12 years old and like I came
home from my Nana's and my mom was like
yeah so uh have some good news you got
the role the small role in Avengers end
game and then you also got the screen
test for Avatar so we're going to fly to
Atlanta and then from Atlanta go to La
and I had never been on the west coast
before and I was like oh my God like I
mean Avengers Avatar scream this is
things are going yeah
will you kindly read our first headline
Jack Fox news reports that Chris Pines
publicist told him is don't worry Darley
press tour hair made him look like he
was Rachel from Friends
cut it all off but um Drew Ross do you
think this was like a compliment or a
dis well I mean
I mean see here oh
the Rachel yeah okay let's see
I don't feel like I look like the Rachel
am I working backwards I I feel like I
look like the sexless Martha
I think it looks great on me actually
I'm kind of into it yeah by the way
yours is going Bieber all the time
wait in fact you used to wear your hair
like Bieber oh my God I know I really
know you don't I yeah I did yeah well I
I see why Chris Pine chopped it off we
are not Jennifer Aniston all right well
up next Insider reports that there's a
new trend on Tick Tock it's quitting
your job quit talk is what it's being
known as it's a feature uh users are
recording themselves as they resign
um now
I like it I read this headline I thought
the videos were going to be like more
Jerry Maguire's style like freakouts you
know with the fish in his hands and you
know but they were actually very calm
and positive
um have you ever quit a job dramatically
or calmly
um I've never quit a job period so uh I
can't I think if I was to quit a job I
don't imagine me you know just slamming
my hand down and be like you know what
I'm done
um but it's good to know that they're
they're positive and you know supportive
I don't know Ross what do you think I
don't know I people quit on the
loudspeaker have you guys seen those
I jumped down the slide and then Jimmy
Fallon sang a song called You Gotta grab
two beers and jump yep exactly yes I
know if I ever quit I'm gonna do it real
dramatic so tune in everybody all right
I've never quitting uh all right we
found this uh this article from the New
York Post uh it's a new study that says
63 of men under 30 are single and most
say that high expectations are why one
man is uh quoted as saying dates feel
like a job interview now and it's a huge
turn off so I I I do you think that
people and I think this from my friends
they always say like I met somebody
online and we've been talking and I
really like him I can't wait to meet him
and I'm like how do you really like him
you don't even know what he smells like
yet and those and those expectations
when you show up like are you the one
are you the one are you the one that is
off-putting yeah um I mean know I'm like
I don't have Tinder or anything like
that but I think it's weird because you
like build a resume for yourself and
then when you go to a job it's like or
to a job when you go to a date it's
almost precisely
yeah literally I think you're you know
um Freudian slip as they say because I
it is like an app you're applying yeah
it's a little you're an applicant
therefore it does feel a bit like a job
instead of something natural yeah
natural because it's kind of like it's
like well you said your favorite color
is red and you know we both like this on
your resume here and you know it's
almost like you're just spewing your
resume in person and I feel like it
takes away from the Romantic naturalness
of it I know I'd love to meet someone in
real life and I that but I will say you
know the few dates I've gone on and I
found from an app because no one's
talking to you IRL because they're
hiding in their app for rejection or
success I am like let's just do this in
person more let's trust that it will all
be okay
hearing yeah but you're like that in
general you're a gut instinct kind of
person wow you are listen I I love I
love it in the movies I love it in real
life
um but I definitely think when it comes
to romance we've got to be more bold and
just put ourselves out there a little
bit more so that we can have occurrences
out in the wild and not just here agreed
agreed agreed
Well Jack you can see him in Scream
sticks knocking it out of the park it's
in theaters tomorrow and uh our next
guest funny enough is looking for love
as well Sheryl Underwood is here and
we're going to talk about what she wants
what she doesn't what we're all figuring
out I love it this is what we do here
yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
oh